The Teen Titans are starting to grow up.
The first look at the series from San Diego
Comic-Con left many DC fans surprised at how
bleak the show looks compared to its contemporaries
at The CW.
But there's a reason why that trailer was
so dark and gritty, and it has a lot to do
with the growth of each of the individual
Titan characters.
Launching in fall 2018, Titans is the flagship
series of the new streaming platform DC Universe,
set to bring exclusive DC Comics content to
viewers no matter what device they're on.
It's a major expansion of DC properties on
TV, whether they're animated or live-action,
and Titans is just one part of it.
Titans may not have the sunny disposition
of the CW's Flash, Supergirl, or Legends of
Tomorrow, and it might be even more angsty
than Arrow.
But that doesn't have to be a bad thing.
Taken on its own terms, DC's Titans just might
have what it takes to blow you away.
The jaded Grayson
The most controversial moment in the Titans
trailer was obviously Robin's F-bomb.
"F--- Batman."
The apparent shift away from the relatively
carefree Teen Titans tone bothered many, but
the show's not necessarily as melodramatic
as that trailer moment makes it appear.
"It is very… dark."
"Of course it's dark.
Night time is the most serious time to fight
crime."
"Yeah, but I can't see anything, either."
Speaking to Polygon, Titans writer and executive
producer Geoff Johns broke down what exactly
Robin's angsty issue with Batman might be,
and what it means for the DC Universe show.
Johns said,
"The trailer shows a piece of the tone of
the show, the show's not all that.
[...] If you look at when Robin first left
Batman in the comics, there was a lot of uneasiness
and him being lost.
Titans is really a series about these different
characters that are all lost in their lives."
While the phrase may not have hit the right
note with a lot of fans, it does a quick job
of establishing a more complex Robin than
the Boy Wonder many are used to.
For casual consumers of pop culture who've
never picked up a comic book, Batman's sidekick
has often come off as a vexing kid brother
type.
"I want a car!
Chicks dig the car."
Titans pushes against this perception, showcasing
a Robin with a chip on his shoulder.
To move out of Batman's shadow, and possibly
become his own hero as Nightwing, he has to
acknowledge that shadow and wrestle with it,
and that's the kind of journey that can only
unfold over a whole season, not just a single
one-liner.
The Outlaw
One of the most promising things we learned
about Titans at Comic-Con didn't show up in
the trailer, and that's the involvement of
Jason Todd.
The second DC comics character to take up
the mantle of Robin, Jason Todd is more popularly
known as the violent hero Red Hood, who stars
in the series Red Hood & The Outlaws.
But long before he two-fisted pistols and
ran with the likes of Bizarro, Todd was a
loyal ally to Batman, a job which ended when
he was brutally, but temporarily, killed by
the Joker.
Whether you love Jason Todd or hate him, the
character is a linchpin in some of DC's most
successful comic book stories, including "Death
in the Family", "Under the Hood", and "Hush".
He's also another example of the way in which
Batman hangs over this new series, letting
lower-tier characters fight it out in a world
that's already been defined by more marquee
heroes.
New worlds
The thing about shared universes is you've
got to be pretty careful about not toppling
all the dominoes over every time you add a
new piece.
Marvel's Cinematic Universe now includes 20
movies and half as many TV shows, restricting
the kinds of stories that can be told at any
given moment.
DC's own Arrowverse is four shows and growing,
with Constantine getting a retroactive inclusion,
Batwoman set to join the universe, and Black
Lightning just waiting in the wings for a
real crossover.
It's a lot to keep in mind for any screenwriter.
Titans, on the other hand, is new territory.
As of now, we don't know how Titans will connect
to other DC properties that already exist,
or if it even will at all.
With DC Universe rolling out multiple live-action
shows in Doom Patrol, Swamp Thing, and Stargirl,
it seems possible that the streaming service's
shows will be their own shared universe, with
Titans serving as the start of something new.
"So the theory of the multiverse - that's
true?"
"True.
Oh yeah, big time."
"Yeah, I still can't believe it and I'm from
another planet."
A clean slate means no baggage, and theoretically,
no restrictions.
The writers of Titans have a rich selection
of DC heroes, villains, stories, and locales
to choose from, who cares if it accidentally
contradicts something from a show that came
before?
Quality source
While the trailer made Titans look like the
show was betraying the source material, the
truth is that the show's producers are taking
inspiration from the very best in Titans comic
history.
Speaking to Polygon, Geoff Johns said the
inspiration for Titans' first season comes
from what he calls "the greatest comic book
Titans run ever": the 1980s New Teen Titans
stories by Marv Wolfman and George Perez.
The influence on the story can be seen in
the trailer, which shows Raven doing whatever
she can to win Robin to her side, just like
in the Wolfman/Perez comics.
Raven is the one who brought the team together
to fight her demonic father Trigon.
We don't know for sure if that villain will
appear in the show, but considering the trailer
appears to be all about fighting inner demons,
it wouldn't be surprising if Raven's dad was
the first season's Big Bad.
The Wolfman/Perez New Teen Titans run had
a major influence on DC Comics, and comics
in general.
Three DC mainstays in Cyborg, Raven, and Starfire
were all introduced, it was in the pages of
that series that Dick Grayson went from being
Robin to Nightwing, and it also brought the
world Slade Wilson, a.k.a. Deathstroke.
Doom Patrol
Joining the Titans on DC Universe are the
team that's been dubbed "the World's Strangest
Heroes", the superhero squad known as Doom
Patrol.
First conceived in the '60s, the title found
a truly unusual voice in the 1980s under writer
Grant Morrison, who took the reins starting
with the series' 19th issue.
Under Morrison's watch, the comic brought
in a truly eclectic group of characters to
root for, from the reality-altering muscle
man Flex Mentallo, to Danny the Street, an
entity of sentient geography.
We don't know exactly what version of Doom
Patrol we'll be getting on TV, but we do know
several of its members will be showing up
in Titans first.
That series has already cast actors for Elasti-Girl,
Robotman, Negative Man, and the team's leader,
Dr. Niles "The Chief" Caulder.
In the comics, Beast Boy was an early member
of Doom Patrol, so it's possible he'll be
used as the connection between the teams.
There is a chance that some of Titan's stars
might end up on the Doom Patrol show, so you're
going to want to get in on the ground floor
to see this.
As of now, we only know that Titans is premiering
in the fall, with Doom Patrol set to join
the service's programming lineup in 2019.
If you sign up quickly enough, you'll be able
to get 15 months of access for the price of
one year, which works out to less than $5
a month.
We've left a link to the upcoming DC Universe
service in the description of this video.
You might even get beta access to the platform,
and get a shot at seeing Titans before anybody
else.
Doorways to anywhere
Speaking to Polygon, Geoff Johns said that
one of the goals with the first Titans season
is to demonstrate that the show can go anywhere,
not just down grim back alleys.
According to Johns,
"We really wanted to lean into the idea that
every [Titan] is a doorway into another genre.
With Rachel [a.k.a. Raven], it's the supernatural
and the horror, and the first season really
focuses on who Raven is and how the Titans
galvanize around her.
You can see that tone in the trailer clearly."
Viewed that way, it makes sense that the Raven-centric
first trailer would have a large amount of
gothic darkness, with the other characters
opening up doorways to different story opportunities.
Being an alien, Starfire would seem to offer
a way into science fiction and space opera
stories, while Robin gives us the same world
of noir mystery as his one-time mentor Batman.
As the series progresses and more members
enter the fold, we're likely to be given keys
to even more worlds and tones of DC.
The Titans can solve mysteries in Gotham City,
fight demons in other dimensions, or blast
off into the stars.
One way or another, the show has a lot more
to offer than just one trailer can show you.
The DC Universe is just beginning, and Titans
is leading the charge.